草生やしたくね？wwwww
www草生やしたいっすわwwwww
というわけで草をたくさん買ってきたわけなんですけどもwwwww
amazonで売ってる草を全部買ってきたwwwww
あの、あれですよwwwww
偽物の草をたくさん買ってきましたwwwww
amazonで売ってる草っぽい草をとりあえず全部買ってきたわけよwwwww
この草を使って今日は草をはやしてやろうかと思いますwwwwwwwwww
wwwwwwwwwってヤツ？
はいwwwww
あぁすいませんwwwww
友達が今、車で来てるんですけどもwwwww
たぶん車の中きれいなんだよあいつはwwwww
そのきれいだった車の中をwwwww
気づいたら草生えまくってて、それになればあいつも草生えるんじゃないかというwwwww
今たぶん下にいるんですけどもwwwww
何とかうまいことこうタイミングを狙ってwwwww
鍵をパクって、車の中入って、車の中をこの植物で覆ってあげましょうwwwww
では草生やすwwwwwwwwwwwwwwwwwwwwwwww
ああ草臭草これほんとに臭いwwwww
臭い臭い臭い、臭い草っすよ:;(∩´﹏`∩);:wwwww
臭ーい臭い臭い臭い臭いwwwww
ええ？入ってこないよね、怖いよねwwwww
やばくね？量がとりあえずwwwww
いやぁこの量ですよwwwww
こっからは作戦だなぁwwwww
ターゲットを誘い出してくださいwwwww
分かりましたwwwww
その間に、カギをパクりますwwwww
二人で車に一気に行って、俺たちは車に仕掛けようwwwww
あ、あ、焦った、それはwwwww
♪wwwwwwwwwwwwwwwwwwwww
頑張ってくださいwwwww
撮り方がすごいなwwwww
強行すぎるでしょwwwww
よしこっからだ、運ぼうぜwwwww
あれ、なくね?なくね?なくね?
え？え？ないよねwwwww
ちょwっとw待っwてwwwww
これだけ先に動かしたほうが良いよねwwwww
鍵どこ？
腰についてんのぉ～wwwwwww
あああ俺～～～さんの車乗ってるじゃないですかwwwww
充電器って落ちてなかった、落ちてなかったですか？wwwww iphoneのwwwww
充電器？wwwww
後ろの席の、下のwwwww
~~~~~横にぽっけあるんすけどwwwww
俺そこ、そこに入れといたんですけど、落としちゃったwwwww
あれでしょ、後ろのっけた時のwwwww
そうそうそうそうwwwww
後で見とくよwwwww
見てきていいすか今wwwww
じゃらじゃらじゃらじゃらじゃらじゃらじゃらじゃらwwwww
前にも乗ったっすね、あ、行っていいすかwwwww
いやぁぁぁぁぁきれいな車ですねwwwww
それじゃさっそく、草生やしますかwwwww
生やしましょうwwwww
なるべく生い茂らせれば勝ちな気がするからwwwww
これだけでもなんか、ぽいなぁwwwww
ﾀｯﾀｯﾀｯﾀｯﾀｯﾀｯﾀﾗﾗ　ﾀｯﾀｯﾀｯﾀｯﾀｯﾀｯﾀwwwww
ﾀﾗﾀﾗﾗﾗﾗｯﾀﾗﾀﾗﾗﾗﾗwwwww
ﾀﾗﾀﾗﾗﾗﾀﾗﾗﾗﾀﾗﾗﾗﾗﾗﾗﾗwwwww
はい、というわけでできましたwwwww
え？！や、やばいじゃんwwwww
奥も結構びっしり詰まっておりますwwwww
もうちょっといけそうwwwww
ﾀﾗﾀﾗﾗﾗﾗｯﾀﾗﾗﾗﾗﾗﾗｯﾀﾗﾗﾗﾗwwwww
やばいなーもうwこれはwww泣いたでしょwwwww
泣いたわこれはwwwww
はい、というわけで車の中はほぼ全部草でございますwwwww
やぁやっぱ、安らぎの効果を得ながら運転してほしいですねwwwww
これだけ草が生えてればたぶん本人も草生えますしwwwww
においもちょっと臭いしwwwww
まぁこれでちょっとでも本人が喜んでくれるとありがたいです！wwwww
じゃぁ本人呼んできまーすwwwww
ちょっと買い出しお願いしてもいい？wwwww
買い出し？wwwww
うん。ポカリスエット10ℓ欲しいんだよねwwwww
じゅwww10wwwww
動画でなんか、10ℓ使いたくてwwwww
一回ちょっとwww買い出しwwwちょ一回wwwww
行ってらっしゃい！wwwww
行ってらっしゃーいwwwww
ohtoo!!!!!!嘘じゃんwwwwwwwwwwwwwwwwwwwwwwwwwwwwwwwwwwwwwwwwwwwwwwwwwwwwwwwwwwwwwwwwww
おいぃwwwwwwwwwwwww
くっｓ.....wwwww
ﾍﾟ↓ﾍﾟ↑ﾍﾟ↓ﾍﾟ↑ﾍﾟ↓ﾍﾟ↑ﾍﾟ↓ﾍﾟ↑ﾍﾟ↓ﾍﾟ↑ﾍﾟ↓ﾍﾟ↑ﾍﾟ↓ﾍﾟ↑ﾍﾟ↓ﾍﾟ↑wwwww
ﾍﾟｰｰｰｰｰwﾍﾟﾍﾟﾍﾟﾍﾟｰﾍﾟｰwwwww
ﾍﾟﾍﾟﾍﾟﾍﾟ↓ﾍﾟ↑ﾍﾟ↓ﾍﾟ↑wwwww
ﾍﾟﾍﾟﾍﾟﾍﾟｰﾍﾟｰwwwww
ﾍﾟﾍﾟﾍﾟﾍﾟｰｰｰｰｰwwwww
ﾓｰﾔｼ☆wwwww
ﾓﾔｼﾓｰﾔｰｼｰｰｰｰｰｰwwwww
ﾍﾟ↓ﾍﾟ↑ﾍﾟ↓ﾍﾟ↑ﾍﾟ↓ﾍﾟ↑ﾍﾟ↓ﾍﾟ↑wwwww
笑笑wwwww